you're watching quite coming up on this
week's show virtual reality we try out
some of the latest headsets and games
and speak to the people behind one of
the hottest tech trends I head to the
Arizona desert with a friend the find
out if VR has to be a lonely game
occurrence and from bomb disposals to
lost in space the world that virtual
reality lets you experience in our game
13 hello and welcome from VR world
congress this event in bristol is all
about virtual reality people are here to
find out about the headsets and the
titles that are changing the world of
gaming a little bit later on i'll be
finding out if it's possible to enter
into a virtual world without appearing
anti-social in the real world but first
let's catch up with stewed who's been
trying out some of the latest VR
technology you've heard the expression
he's off in his own little world got him
well I'm taking that to new extremes
thanks to virtual reality I'm quite
literally the king of my own little
canceled how'd I do could do better but
not bad for a first attempt well there's
lots more people than when we started
it's amazing you are you're fully in on
you you're you're one in a room in
bristow you are completely there stood
on your castle defending your tower yeah
it's real yeah let me ask you about
setup because we've got these sensors
just over on the walls and it's
obviously quite a big space so if I had
a flat with a tiny living room what's my
option there if I want to get the HTC
vive the cool thing is is actually you
can define the space you want to play in
so when I take it home I've got a pretty
small lounge actually so I did it in a
space about so like two meters by two
meters you can do it sat down on a chair
of you want all entertainment has been a
rectangle what I mean by that is whether
you're looking at a silver screen or you
look at the television set right now or
your smartphone you're looking at
rectangle with VR we step through the
window we step through the rectangle
into a volume it's also going to take a
little bit of getting used to that's
going to be a completely new world
that's very very exciting a range of
headsets are vying for your attention if
you go one way there are the top end
models like oculus rift HTC vive and
PlayStation VR these costs between 350
and just under 700 pounds or you could
go the other way for headsets that act
as a case for your phone strapping it on
to your face like Samsung gear google
cardboard or merge these are much more
affordable and could be an option if
you'd like to try virtual reality
without spending too much money this is
most certainly Year Zero I would say and
I think things are only going to get
bigger from now rather than necessarily
everything being suddenly you know
everywhere I wouldn't expect it you know
quite this year but they are to be in
everyone's homes yet you know that we
know we've got a way to go but the whole
industry knows that as well if the
technology can live up to people's
expectations and be accepted by the
masses there's no telling the height
virtual reality could reach Stewart
Duggan's sky knees stay with us still to
come I try out some multiplayer VR take
what else has been going on in the world
of Patrick week facebook wants to create
chat bots for its messenger app that
will perfectly mimic humans the company
reckons the technology would help us do
things like book flights or find out
what's going on in the news allowing
businesses to create customer service
BOTS within messenger could be one way
for facebook to monetize the platform
more than 900 million people used the
app every month
if you like a bit of air guitar band how
about trying we're guitar a team in the
US has created a wristband that
simulates playing an instrument you just
sync it up to an appt the project called
air jams is raising money on Kickstarter
this is move it take a look at one
IndieGoGo campaigns answer to
personalizing your workouts this is move
it all in one fitness equipment the
makers call it the world's first mobile
connected smart home gym sensors link up
to software keeping an eye on your
progress and letting you send exercise
challenges to your friend no studies for
plan and scientists using an underwater
robot have found a monster in Loch Ness
but it's not the one they were hoping to
spot it was just a model used in a 1970s
Sherlock Holmes film but at least it was
the right shape the robots been scanning
the lock to try and finally solve the
Nessie mystery stick around there's a
race against the clock to save your
friends tense drama in our virtual
reality games review when you're trying
out virtual reality you're meant to be
completely
goggles and headphones on it might have
a little bit antisocial but actually
there are vr social networks and you can
play VR games with other people as I
found out hey is that you en hi I can
see you in a virtual world hey let's
shake hands yeah do that yeah haha how
do you do this must be a multiplayer
then tell me about it so this is Arizona
sunshine as you can see we're in a the
Arizona sunshine and if you look in
front there's a there's a table with
everything on it which is quite cool
there's like a map and a compass can we
pick these things up hand me them are so
should we try that hey I'm holding a mom
hahaha it's really cool but hang on if
you play this with your friends yeah
they've all got to have the same
equipment haven't it enough that's
pretty expensive these headsets aren't
cheap yeah that's right and I think as
with any new technology the cost of
entry you know it changes and whether
it's like a samsung gear vr or a
PlayStation VR and through to the HTC
vive and oculus the cost does change as
you go up the experience on more virtual
reality games becoming multiplayer so
that more people can play at the same
time and it's a bit more sociable yeah
absolutely so this is part of the second
loss multiplayer game I've seen and so
it's certainly very interactive what
about the drawbacks ian because i feel
like there's a bit of a latency
maybe I'm just not very good at picking
up these items but tell me about some of
the downsides it's still an early stage
development really isn't it a grander
scheme of things um kind of but also
it's it's thoroughly improved over such
a short period of time so I finally if
you hold the trigger down on the
controller you'll hold on to the rock or
the bottle bet and actually it's quite
intuitive so I can juggle this rock I'm
if you can see me juggling the rock but
oh yeah Oh Barry oh that's it I can drop
it a juggler and about your world it's
Ali I'm not going to juggling a real
world I'm really keen to see what we're
actually doing and what we look like in
the real world I'm gonna take this
headset often see like yeah let's do
that oh you're over there you don't even
facing me so you've seen more virtuosity
soon this will be the moon we are gaming
in your bedroom or your living but what
games should you try out first it's tom
from stuff magazine it's picked up again
today we're grilling meat with a side of
me as all the vegetables need mainly
need and we're a threat against a wall
the year is 2050 and robots now do all
of the blue-collar work humans to get a
sense of what it used to be like to be a
nine-to-five fleshy drone enter a
simulator and get taught the experience
by job bot yes this is really really
silly stuff job bot will run you through
a bunch of very menial tasks like
photocopying or making the coffee but
the experience comes alive because using
the vive controllers you can interact
with practically every object in front
of you so rather than follow the simple
tasks it's more fun to just mess around
and be like guys I got this stuff right
over here cool check it out stapler why
not try photocopying the stapler
throwing paper aeroplanes at your fellow
workers or eating that moldy doughnut
and seeing what happens there are so far
for jobs to do office worker diner chef
mechanic and shop worker and each one is
just as hilarious as the other if Tamara
open up shop the pro maneuver if you're
looking to introduce virtual reality
somebody who doesn't usually play games
this is the game to do it with
warning hand for eb a suit critically
damaged Cory you know the film gravity
where Sandra Bullock gets stuck in space
running out of oxygen with no way to get
home this game is just like that you
wake up on a derelict spaceship leaking
oxygen from your spacesuit and you have
to really quickly figure out what the
heck's going on how to get your
spaceship systems back online and how to
get back to earth it works absolutely
brilliantly in VR as you look around
your heads moving within the helmet of
the spacing which gives you a real sense
of claustrophobia but for me it's a
daunting in a good way no other game has
come close to simulating the experience
of floating in zero gravity for a
spaceship but that's not to say
everybody's going to be immediately
comfortable with it oculus have given
this an intense rating and it can make
you feel a little bit weird at least for
the first few minutes it's an incredibly
immersive involving an affecting
experience and a brilliant showcase for
VR okay i see a bark it's got wires like
keypad if you thought vr was a lonely
solo experience keep talking and nobody
explodes is here to change your mind
with its take on VR multiplayer it's
very sturdy mere five minutes it's going
down one player puts on the headset and
in front of them can see a bomb ticking
down to their demise every other player
in the room has the instructions to
disarm the bomb but they can't actually
see it so it's up to the player with the
headset to describe what they see so
that the other players can find the
right instructions and then it's up to
the guys with the instructions to try to
describe the disarmament process to the
player with the headset it is really
complicated it's also incredibly good
fun really silly and really quite tense
for the person with the VR headset
well that's it for this week take a look
at sky moves on mobile tablet catch-up
and sky cube all the latest tech stories
throughout the week we'll see you again
next time bye-bye